hi-yah today we are learning English
with Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban you know this was actually one
of my favorite books and movies of the
Harry Potter series because it's kind of
when we start seeing the characters
becoming adults and so the movie had a
bit more of a level of maturity than the
first two and by the way if you're new
here every single week we help you to
understand fast speaking natives without
getting lost without using the jokes and
without subtitles
just like daniel who said that he thinks
we are the number one channel for
learning english and we're excited to
join you on your journey to english
fluency - all you have to do is hit that
subscribe button and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our new lessons
now let's roll over to Hogwarts
[Music]
and must you've got to stop them they've
got the wrong man true sir Sirius is
innocent please believe us
I do miss Granger but I'm sorry to say
the word of three thirteen year old
Wizards will convince few others a
child's voice
whoever honest and true is meaningful to
those have forgotten parallelism
mysterious thing time powerful and when
meddled with dangerous serious blacks is
in the topmost cell of the Dark Tower
you know the laws Miss Granger
he must not be seen and you would do
well I feel to return before this last
time if not the consequences are too
ghastly to discuss if you succeed
tonight more than one innocent life may
be spared three times should do anything
oh by the way when in doubt I find
retracing my steps to be a wise place to
begin good luck what the bloody hell was
that all about
sorry Ron but seeing as you can't walk
[Music]
what does happen what's wrong
seven-thirty where are we at 7:30 I know
going hybrid come on and we can't be
seen
[Music]
and mas you've got to stop them
they've got the wrong man true sir
Sirius is innocent if you've watched
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
you should know that Harry's Godfather
Sirius Black escapes prison and spends
the whole movie being searched for as he
was accused of committing very serious
crimes years ago so later at the end of
the movie Harry and his friends learned
that Sirius was not guilty that is he
did not actually commit those crimes
you've got to stop them they've got the
wrong man
so Hermione is telling Dumbledore that
Sirius who everyone's been looking for
is actually innocent
she says that they've got the wrong man
this is a common phrase used in these
situations when the police or any
authority has caught the wrong person
who is not responsible for the crime
that was committed stay out my business
you're blaming the wrong guy please
believe us
I do miss Granger's myths is a title
used before the family name of a single
woman while mrs. is used to address a
married woman please believe us did you
listen to how Hermione pronounced this
phrase words in English that end in the
letter e normally have it as a silent E
in the case of the verb believe this is
how you should pronounce it believe
believe another common occurrence in
spoken English is the linking of sounds
in separate words for example with the
verb and pronoun believe us believe us
please believe us this happens very
often to these combinations of verb plus
personal pronouns such as us you or it
listen to these other examples
well wrongs told us all about you of
course when did he get here you're going
to expel us aren't you not today mr.
Weasley
come Dobby
please believe us I do miss Granger but
I'm sorry to say the word of three
13-year old Wizards will convince a few
others a child's voice forever honest
and true is meaningless to those who
capitalism someone who is honest always
tells the truth or does not cheat or
steal so is something such as an opinion
or message is said to be honest that
means it does not try to hide the truth
or the facts about something now I'll
make you a deal I'll tell you all about
the roosevelt riot if you tell me
something honest about yourself like
this brother you're road-tripping with
how do you feel about him a child's
voice whoever honest and truth is
meaningful to those capitalism if
something is considered meaningless it
has no real value purpose or
significance
you are about to die the hands of the
children of Thanos be thankful that your
meaningless lives and now contribute
balance is closed today
I've been working for 10 years now at
this meaningless dead-end job and nobody
here even knows that I exist
Chandler Dumbledore is saying that
although children are honest and speak
the truth they're considered irrelevant
and ignored by people who have forgotten
how to listen mysterious thing time
powerful and when meddled with dangers
to meddle is to interfere to try to
change or have an influence on things
that are not your responsibility
especially without being welcomed to do
so example I don't want my parents
meddling in my marriage now you listen
to me all three of you you're meddling
in things that ought not to be meddled
in it's dangerous so here
Dumbledore speaks in a poetic way about
the notion of time saying that it is a
mysterious thing and also powerful but
dangerous when people interfere with it
if you've watched the movie you know
Dumbledore is referring to the time
Turner in the Wizarding World a time
Turner is a magical device used for time
travel that resembles an hourglass on a
necklace hey I've got a question for you
would you like to be able to understand
natives no matter how fast we speak then
why not try our fluent with friends
course in this 48 week course every week
you will get a lesson that is teaches
you English falling along with the first
two seasons of the series friends plus
you get 20 plus page PDF power lessons
access to our fluency circle global
community vocabulary memorization
software and so much more and you can
try for free right now what are you
waiting for it to sign up for our master
class by clicking up here or down in the
script
below Sirius Black is in the topmost
cell of the Dark Tower in this context a
cell is a small empty room where
prisoners are kept the topmost something
is something that is at the highest
position somewhere the topmost cell of
the dark tower is the highest cell
located in the dark tower you know the
law is Miss Granger you must not be seen
he's referring to the rules established
for the use of the time Turner and also
the natural laws of time existing in the
universe of Harry Potter you will do
what I feel to return before this last
time if you say that somebody would do
well to do something you mean that it
would be good for them and that you
recommend them to do it this is a rather
formal collocation example you would do
well the higher lawyer now in case this
becomes a lawsuit Aleister we never use
Transfiguration as a punishment
surely Dumbledore told you that you
might have mentioned it what you will do
well to remember it wait
so Dumbledore is recommending Hermione
use the time Turner and return to this
room before the last bell sound the
chime which they just heard if not the
consequences are too costly to discuss
gastly is an adjective meaning
unpleasant in a way that causes great
horror or fear this is not a very common
word now in a different more usual
application if you say that someone
looks ghastly they look very ill or very
shocked especially with a very pale face
example you look ghastly are you ok
if you succeed tonight more than one
innocent life may be spared the word
spare generally describes something that
is extra additional it may have
different meanings as a noun a verb or
an adjective in the collocation used by
Dumbledore to spare life it means to
save a life especially of someone who
has been sentenced to death such as
serious a turn as a noun refers to a
move in a circular direction around an
axis or point if you say to someone that
something should or will do it you are
informally tying than that thing will be
enough example would you like anything
else no that'll do it
[Music]
that should do it
feel better much thank you Dumbledore's
saying that three turns of the time
Turner should be enough to accomplish
their goal oh by the way when in doubt I
find retracing my steps to be a wise
place to begin by the way is a polite
way to add extra information used in
both formal and informal contexts excuse
me
demand everywhere else is full not at
all
I'm gone by the way from Weasley I'm
Harry Harry Potter to retrace somebody
steps is to discover and follow a route
or course taken by someone example the
detective is investigating the crime
while trying to retrace the victim steps
wise in this case means prudent oh by
the way when in doubt I find retracing
my steps to be a wise place to begin
so Dumbledore is telling them that if
they're not sure of where to start they
should follow their own steps from
earlier as that would be an intelligent
and safe way to get started
bloody how was that all about this is an
interesting example of two informal
collocations being used in the same
sentence to put in a simple way Ron
basically just asked what was that all
about
however he used the informal expressions
the hell and bloody together to add a
sense of shock and surprise to his
question example what the hell are you
doing you can't come in here
get it off
[Music]
how the hell is this dude still alive
bloody hell was that all about
in British English the adjective bloody
when used as slang like done here adds
intensity and emotion to a sentence
emphasizing what you are saying in a
slightly rude way example this computer
is bloody useless it's always breaking
down besides if Uncle Vernon I'm warning
you if you don't control that bloody
bird it'll have to go hey Harry Potter
fan if you are a muggle who is
fascinated with the Wizarding World then
be sure to check out all of our lessons
featuring Harry Potter in this playlist
after you finish this lesson what just
happened what's wrong 7:30
well we at 7:30 I know going here Harry
means going to Hagrid's house when you
see somebody refer to a place as a
person's name plus apostrophe s it means
the person's home Joey sorry oh that's
gonna leave a stain Rach hey it's fine
you're at Joey's look
[Music]
and master you've got to stop them
they've got the wrong man
true sir Sirius is innocent please
believe us
I do miss Granger but I'm sorry to say
the word of three thirteen-year-old
Wizards will convince few others a
child's voice whoever honest and true is
meaningful to those of the capitalism
mysterious thing time powerful and when
meddled with dangerous serious blacks is
in the topmost cell of the Dark Tower
you know the laws Miss Granger
you must not be seen and you would do
well I feel to return before this last
time if not the consequences are too
ghastly to discuss if you succeed
tonight more than one innocent life may
be spared
three times should do anything
[Music]
oh by the way when in doubt I find
retracing my steps to be a wise place to
begin good luck what the bloody hell was
that all about
sorry Ron but seeing as you can't walk
[Music]
what does happen what's wrong
seven-thirty where are we at 7:30 I know
going hybrid come on and we can't be
seen
[Music]
come on
haha yeah I hope you had a lot of fun
joining me in the Wizarding World today
and if you want to get English fluency
magically fast and then why not hit that
subscribe button so you don't miss any
of our lessons featuring movies like
Harry Potter and series that you love
now it's time to go beyond the classroom
and live your English oh yeah